un sourire à peine esquissés mais un
sourire tout de même le premier sur la
bouche de la mer d'alexia celle qui a
tout fait basculer dit la vérité en
ayant bien insisté sur le fait que vous
l'a aimée 30 en disant que c'était une
autre fille il a fallu l'intervention de
votre intervention madame pour que dire
l'émotion m'emporte villeneuve sur lot
n'est ce qu'il reconnaisse sa
responsabilité pleine et entière et
unique
après deux confrontations stériles avec
son beau frère et sa belle soeur dont
ils fuyaient le regard john alton
d'avaler finalement tombé à genoux
devant la mère de sa victime
implorant son pardon de ses larmes une
délivrance pour grégory gay enfin lavé
de tout soupçon ça aurait pu pousser
certaines personnes à suffit de manger
décidé de l'abattre
j'ai bien fait ma demande et la
confrontation on l'a eu il a craqué
aujourd'hui et retombe sur ses aveux ont
tant on tend vers la vraie histoire
encore des choses à dire mais c'est dur
encore passion l'a souhaité on l'a
tellement la voulais tellement pouvoir
jeudi raconter des choses
un bureau d'un juge au regard regardez
les personnes qu'on accuse droit dans
les yeux en racontant sa version c'est
pas pareil
il reste pourtant des zones d'ombré dans
ces nouveaux aveux johnattan d'aval
explique une dispute conjugale à son
domicile découvre une chute dans les
escaliers
une version qui ne collent toujours pas
avec les constatations médico-légales
les violences graves constatées sur le
corps de la victime ne sont pas
parfaitement compatible avec sa version
à l'heure actuelle le corps a bien été
retrouvé partiellement brûlée et il
réaffirme qu'il a agi seul
ce sont des zones d'ombré qui nécessite
quelques quelques investigations
complémentaires en tout cas un
interrogatoire au fond de nouveau de
monsieur de monsieur d'avant la famille
de johnatan venus le soutenir par la
pensée sous le choc
ses avocats salue la fin d'un douloureux
déni on est face à une version qu'il
très cohérente par rapport aux éléments
objectifs du dossier que tout n'a pas
été dit par johnathan navale c'est
difficile de reconnaître qu'on a tué la
femme qu'on aimait ils l'aiment toujours
et je crois que c'est pas la maman
d'alexis à qui vous dira le contraire
c'est ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui et
il y aura une reconstitution
l'instruction n'est donc pas tout à fait
terminée pour johnattan d'aval un
suspect est passé deux fois aux aveux
c'est